i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález francia
comienza ya la recta final para la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales del 10 de abril el
presidente manuel marco favorito en las
encuestas ha presentado un leve descenso
en el porcentaje de la intención de voto
muchos lo aducen a que el presidente ha
tenido que estar también pendiente de
algunos asuntos europeos y por supuesto
de la guerra en ucrania y eso le ha
quitado un poco de visibilidad entre los
franceses
aún así marco ha sacado tiempo para
visitar algunas ciudades intermedias y
algunas poblaciones desde donde ha
enviado su mensaje político en donde
refuerza sus valores pro europeos pero
también critica la extrema derecha
veamos sé por qué lucho por qué valores
luchó como candidato por qué valores
luche como presidente y estoy luchando a
nivel internacional porque francia estoy
luchando en europa si el extrema derecha
hace 5 años hubiera ganado no había
tenido una vacuna porque nos hubiéramos
ido de europa y francia no produjo una
vacuna y la extrema derecha de hace
cinco años si hubiera ganado podría
haber tenido el ibrox y cloroquina
porque esa era la creencia del muy bien
si la extrema derecha hubiera ganado
hace cinco años
porque eso lo que se creía esa es la
realidad también hay que decirlo
la segunda las encuestas es marín de
veterana en el mundo de la política
francesa también es la líder de la
extrema derecha este es su tercer
intento por llegar al palacio del elíseo
la líder del reagrupamiento nacional ha
llevado a cabo una campaña un poco más
discreta digámoslo así si se compara con
la campaña anterior en esta intenta
mostrarse como una política un poco más
convencional mucho más moderada aunque
durante algunos eventos políticos marine
lepén ha criticado al presidente majo a
quien lo acusa del deterioro de la
calidad de vida de los franceses
escuchemos no se trata de intuición se
trata de proximidad es porque soy una
candidata que está lo más cerca posible
de la gente que inmediatamente a través
de las discusiones que tuve con ellos
lectores me di cuenta de lo urgente que
era tener una respuesta al costo de vida
porque el aumento de los precios de la
energía no se ha hecho esperar a la
guerra de ucrania la realidad es que
manuel mac con incluso ha contribuido a
ello porque fue él quien empeoró los
impuestos a los combustibles lo que en
realidad provocó el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos
otra cara conocida en el escenario
político francés jean-luc mélenchon es
tal vez la figura más fuerte que tiene
la izquierda francesa que está bastante
dispersa para estas elecciones es
reconocido por sus discursos polémicos y
enérgicos en los que carga contra la
globalización contra las élites
políticas pero también lo hace contra
sus dos contrincantes más cercanos
escuchemos
no estoy confundiendo al señor macro ni
la señora lepén eso no es lo que estoy
diciendo pero también sé que hay una
diferencia
el señor macrón es el programa económico
de la señora lepén más el desprecio de
clase la señora lepén es el programa
económico del señor macrón más el
desprecio racial
con un discurso anti islámico y anti
inmigración el ex periodista y
comentarista de televisión eric simón ha
ganado seguidores tanto del epen y de la
derecha más fuerte que está establecida
y también algunos seguidores del
presidente ma con 12 candidatos en total
están participando en esta contienda del
lector electoral ocho hombres cuatro
mujeres compiten en esta primera vuelta
que se muestra menos emocionante que
algunos comicios anteriores pero que sin
duda alguna pues van a decidir cuáles
son los dos candidatos que se van a
enfrentar en la segunda vuelta que
tendrá lugar solamente dos semanas
después hoy en el debate de france 24 la
recta final de las elecciones
presidenciales en francia en donde los
sondeos ya comienzan a apretarse a
ajustarse y cualquier porcentaje es
vital para los candidatos para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a eugénie
ricard ella es investigadora de la
facultad de finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado de colombia
eugene se encuentra en la ciudad de
bogotá y en la capital colombiana
también está nuestro siguiente invitado
aymerich dije él es analista
internacional él es 12 relaciones
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad javeriana también ubicada en
la ciudad de bogotá ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con los comentarios y las
preguntas que deseen hacernos lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 guión bajo s y arroba sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal le
recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 dejen todos sus preguntas
y comentarios todos son bienvenidos
comienza entonces dándole la bienvenida
al programa eugene como siempre un gusto
tenerla en el programa es una cara
conocida aquí en el debate de france 24
eugene y estamos todavía a varias
semanas un par de semanas de esta
primera vuelta de las elecciones en
francia pero ya las encuestas nos dan
por lo menos una foto de cómo pueden ser
las intenciones de voto cuáles son sus
opiniones o análisis en torno a estos
resultados preliminares de las encuestas
como podrían cambiar de cara a esta
primera vuelta
bueno lo que nos demuestra hoy en día
los sondeos es que sin duda marcó
entonces es el candidato favorito pero
nunca ganará en primera vuelta estamos
casi seguros de tener una segunda vuelta
lo que no tenemos todavía claro es
contra quien macro se va a enfrentar en
segunda vuelta como usted lo hice pues
es posible que sea más y le pen que hoy
en día estaba 21 por ciento de las
intenciones de voto mientras marco está
en 28 pero también podría ser la
sorpresa el candidato son rick mensual
que es la digamos la opción más ancha en
la izquierda y que se vende un poquito
con el voto útil
- son dice si usted no quieren volver a
repetir este duelo de macrolane que
finalmente es la derecha en contra de la
extrema derecha pues yo soy el hombre
indicado entonces todavía no está muy
claro lo que sí está claro es que esta
campaña está muy apagada usted lo ha
dicho esto se debe a varios factores
primero pues el escenario internacional
con el cual estamos jugando ha hecho que
mccourt sea ha sido mucho más presidente
que candidato de hecho él sabe que esta
conyuntura internacionales sirve y le da
mucho más visibilidad a su candidatura
pero también porque más coalición no
hacer debates entonces estamos en un
escenario un poquito más apagado una
cosa más que es importante decir es que
la tanto la derecha como la izquierda
vienen perdiendo digamos electores
mientras que los extremos tanto extrema
derecha como extrema izquierda se están
fortaleciendo
esto nos marca también un punto
importante o jim jam eric y es que estas
encuestas marcan un momento puntual de
la intención de voto de los ciudadanos
pero el resultado de las elecciones pues
sigue siendo incierto sigue siendo algo
incierto porque hasta dentro de dos
semanas no va a tener lugar estos
comicios y todo puede cambiar por eso lo
decía yo en la introducción cada
porcentaje que pierda o gane uno de los
candidatos en este momento es sumamente
importante para ellos le hago la
pregunta para el punto de partida y me
dije también le doy la bienvenida al
programa y quiero conocer entonces sus
impresiones de estas encuestas y cómo se
pueden perfilar los candidatos y los
porcentajes de voto que quedan de
aquellas personas que están indecisas
a esos comisiones el 10 de abril
buenas tardes santiago muchas gracias
por la invitación
como lo dijo
el presidente macro es el favorito según
las encuestas de opinión para clasificar
en la segunda vuelta y para ganar en la
segunda vuelta sin embargo hay una
acompaña a pegada como lo dijo rené pero
una desilusión un poco democrática
frente al escenario que es el más
probable que es un escenario de tener la
misma segunda vuelta que en las últimas
elecciones del 2017 detener la macro
llama generó pena entonces debemos tener
mucho cuidado frente a las encuestas de
opinión tomar en cuenta la incertidumbre
de muchos votantes que todavía no se han
definido bien y también una
incertidumbre en cuanto al nivel de
participación podría haber más ausencia
más abstención de lo normal mientras que
habitualmente la elección presidencial
es la dirección que al mayor interés de
los ciudadanos es solamente un punto de
partida todo puede cambiar de cara al 10
de abril continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa hablemos de los
temas de campaña aquí en américa latina
no conocemos a profundidad cuáles son
los temas internos que preocupan a los
franceses en este momento y claramente
esta
campaña ha tenido un sabor diferente
están en un momento tras el pico de la
pandemia un país que fue muy afectado en
el número de casos y de muertos por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y pues claramente un
tema que es transversal para todo el
continente europeo que es la guerra en
euro en un cráneo
si a veces hubo elecciones con un tema
claro de compañía electoral un tema
central apoyo será la seguridad a veces
más el tema económico este año no veo
realmente un tema central clave porque
ya primero no hay debates entonces cada
candidato hace su propia acompaña por
supuesto ahí el candidato es de extrema
derecha más sobre el tema de seguridad
de identidad otros más sobre un tema de
economía pero la ausencia de verdaderos
debates impide tener una claridad y una
compañía común de todos los candidatos
ahora bien es cierto que el tema de la
guerra en ucrania es un tema central muy
importante por la coyuntura
internacional pero como es difícil
también porque pues ahí el presidente
que habla de este tema pero no puede
hablar lo de manera totalmente libre
porque está también en cargo está en
diálogo con dyn los demás candidatos
también buscan hablar de otros temas a
veces porque el tema de política
exterior tradicionalmente no es el tema
más importante en los temas de las
compañías electorales entonces nos
habían preparado mucho en hablar de este
tipo de tema eugene y su opinión de la
agenda de las campañas de los temas que
deben priorizar los ciudadanos y que se
han quedado sobre la mesa precisamente
por esta falta de debates y de
confrontación de ideas que es lo que le
preocupa a los franceses en este momento
bueno la sociedad francesa en este
momento está muy dividida efectivamente
a la derecha tenemos un tema recurrente
que es el tema de la migración y de la
identidad nacional los dos candidatos de
extrema derecha marine lepén eric asimov
han intentado entonces imponer esta esta
temática y sabemos que el electorado de
la derecha está muy apegado a este tema
sin embargo hay otros el poder
adquisitivo es un tema que le preocupa
mucho a los franceses muchos han perdido
empleos durante la pandemia a sus
ingresos se han visto afectados aunque
el estado franceses le ha respondido
mucho a la gente de las empresas por
este tema pero hay un tema bien
importante
es el tema de las pensiones estamos
hablando de una sociedad que está
envejeciendo hay un debate para saber si
las pensiones la gente se podría jubilar
a los 60 a los 62 años o incluso a los
65 y también tenemos un tema que es muy
importante que es transversal a todos
los programas pero que está ganando
siempre más importancia no solamente en
francia sino en europa es el tema de la
transición ecológica es decir el medio
ambiente ya se dio cuenta que no
solamente tiene que ver con el planeta
también tiene que ver con su economía
también tiene que ver con sus empresas
la competitividad del país y entonces
hay un gran debate por ejemplo en este
momento en el cual nos declaramos pues
vulnerables energéticamente del gas de
rusia y entonces
bajo la planteó la necesidad por ver por
ejemplo de volver a la unión europea de
fortalecerla para hacer un mercado que
digamos sea autosostenible desde el
punto de vista energético o bien sea con
gas con petróleo o con energía nuclear
eugene usted toca el tema de la unión
europea los temas energéticos el tema
medioambiental qué proyección plantean
estos candidatos de francia dentro de la
unión europea sabemos que hay candidatos
como por ejemplo marine lepén que la
campaña anterior decía que retiraría a
francia del bloque europeo tan pronto
llegar a la presidencia ahora ha
moderado un poco este discurso y ya no
lo plantea de esta forma cuál es la
proyección que hacen del país dentro del
bloque comunitario
bueno hay varios candidatos toman tanto
de extrema izquierda como extrema
derecha que se sienten un poquito
incómodos con este tema es discutido
porque al principio no lo condenaron muy
fuertemente incluso lo veía como un
líder ahora pues ya han bajado el tema
sobre sobre putin pero este tema de la
unión europea es un tema que realmente
divide a emanuel makoun del resto de los
candidatos y más que todo de los
extremos emanuel manu ha demostrado ser
un europeo convencido está para el
fortalecimiento de las instituciones y
también la composición de un ejército
europeo y de una política exterior y una
política militar europea y aquí tiene
una posición muy fuerte que le permite
concentrar todos los votos de la derecha
y de la izquierda tradicional mientras
que los extremos están más para una
disminución digamos de francia dentro de
la esfera europea por todos los todos
los impuestos y todo en digamos la
reglamentación que eso implica sin
embargo
este tema de salir de la unión europea
ya no está tanto dentro de los discursos
hoy en día los discursos son muy
pragmáticos los extremos saben que
tienen que recoger los votos sobre unas
temáticas muy cotidianas de la gente
como el poder adquisitivo como el precio
de la energía y no tanto sobre unos
grandes discursos digamos de por dónde
va a francia desde un punto de vista
digamos de identidad o de pertenecer o
no a la opinión a la unión europea
además que en un momento de coyuntura
como la guerra en ucrania el llamado es
a la unión a mantenerse fortalecidos y
retirarse de la unión europea no un
escenario como éste pues tendría un
costo muy alto a nivel político para no
solamente para francia sino para
cualquier país que lleve a cabo este
tipo de acción aymerich que quiero
preguntarle por esos votos de los
indecisos de las personas que aún no
saben por quién van a votar y las
minorías puntuales
en francia que van a ser cruciales para
la decisión del presidente en estos
comicios estoy hablando del voto de los
migrantes que han llegado al país que
son jóvenes que se enfrentan también a
la primera vez que van a participar en
unos comicios el voto de la comunidad
musulmana que es muy importante también
allí y
estas personas que todavía no saben por
quién van a votar esto cómo se perfila
para parar los comicios
si hay puedo yo creo que hay ciertos
candidatos que justamente intentan
seducir un poco esta parte de de los
jóvenes de los habitantes de barrios
populares que vigente no votan mucho a
veces y hay en particular el candidato
son menos o que busca realmente atraer a
estos votantes para alcanzar para
calificarse en la segunda vuelta y el
reemplazará a martín lo tengo como
competidor frente a manuel marco pero
quería añadir si me permiten en el té
sobre el tema europeo yo creo que no
había candidatos realmente salvo un
candidato muy con muy pocos votos que
que vaya que recomendaba la salida
realmente de la un número casi nos la
salida de la de la moneda de la zona
euro para volver a tener una moneda
nacional y es sobre este tema que marín
en cambio y ya no habla de salir de la
de la moneda común pero
no había voluntariamente de salir de la
unión europea y el tema es tal vez en un
punto a ucrania es más sobre el rol de
francia en la otan y la política de
defensa de francia que realmente el tema
europeo claro yo hago la aclaración que
cuando me refiero a la candidata marie
le pen ella tenía esta postura en la
candidatura anterior lo decía la
introducción para estos comicios ha
cambiado un poco su posición y ha
mantenido una postura un poco más
moderada en torno a la permanencia de
francia en la zona euro en la zona de la
unión europea y como lo menciona el
médico en la otan en donde francia es un
actor muy importante quiero que hablemos
ahora de los candidatos ya vimos el país
como en una perspectiva más global en
cuanto a los temas y ya la posición que
tiene en el continente europeo comienzo
por él por el presidente y candidato
manuel marco muchos lo han criticado por
haber comenzado prácticamente hacer
campaña solamente dos semanas antes de
los comicios el presidente lo han
señalado el bank credit cado por haber
estado
dedicado al tema de ucrania los temas
europeos y esto le puede jugar en contra
ya se nota en los primeros sondeos de
opinión y de porcentajes de intención de
voto le va a jugar en contra el
presidente para mantenerse como líder
como lo ve usted aymerich
no yo creo que sobre todo la
preocupación actual de mccomb es sobre
un informe del senado que ha sido
publicado el 17 de marzo y que demuestra
un uso muy importante por parte del
gobierno de
consultorías con pagos muy elevados a
cerca de mil millones de euros y una
cercanía también que existe entre
ciertos asesores que trabajan en
particular con mckinsey una consultoría
que han sido también que participaron en
la acompaña en el partido para el
político ver dónde manuel mckeown del
partido la república en marcha y en este
momento hay muchas críticas sobre este
tema del uso de las consultorías de
muchos gastos públicos para usar estas
consultorías para las decisiones
a los diferentes ministerios para por
ejemplo en cuanto a la pondrían con
todas las decisiones de de
vacunación etcétera entonces creo que es
el tema en este momento más problemático
para el la desconexión que existe insúa
digamos que su
participación pues tuvo su lado de
actuar sobre la wifi exterior sobre de
seguir siendo el presidente es una
crítica clásica que se hace a todos los
presidentes salientes
en su opinión desconexión la
participación en esta política exterior
como presidente tiene que continuar
porque además de candidato es el
presidente de france y tiene que
mantener el país en marcha
si el marco ha tenido el deseo de ser
una campaña muy corta imitando un
poquito de lo que había hecho nicolas
sarkozy también para su reelección es
decir una campaña corta en la cual no se
toma muchos riesgos él ha utilizado el
contexto de la guerra ni ucrania para
decir yo quiero ser presidente hasta el
último cuarto de hora pero porque es
verdad que es mucho más cómodo moverse
desde esa posición cuando uno se vuelve
candidato pues puede ser blanco de todas
las críticas y más aún cuando uno va
punteando en las encuestas pues ya todo
el mundo empieza a atacar el primero
para hacerlo bajar entonces en el
macondo se quería desgastar en una
campaña
quería hacer una campaña muy rápido pero
obviamente ya los franceses están
empezando a pedirle cuentas y más que
todo como decía enric pues que hay un
muy mal muy mal esta noticia en la cual
la gente tiene tanta dificultad
económica estos gastos absolutamente
increíbles de lilís de en unos camiones
de su consultoría 800 millones de euros
al marquense que es únicamente que
sabemos a trabajo y también te para la
campaña de macro entonces ahora marco
está acusado de de haberlo dado unos
contratos digamos para agradecerles
digamos de su apoyo en su campaña
entonces aquí es una noticia que cayó
muy mal entonces en todo este revuelto
en el cual los franceses se sienten un
poquito no muy escuchados cansados ya
han sufrido mucho para el corrido pues
tener este presidente que que se
preocupa más por cuestiones de
relaciones interiores de relaciones
exteriores y de su imagen digamos que
que gasta mucha plata también para
cuidar su imagen pues los franceses
sienten que este presidente no está muy
cercano y no se preocupa necesariamente
por sus problemas cotidianos y eso
explica también que sube entonces la
intención de voto de la extrema derecha
eugene ya lo decíamos al presidente le
están cobrando factura de estos
contratos con estas consultoras y
también esta ausencia en la campaña pero
si algo ha logrado generar en la guerra
en ucrania es digamos un llamado efecto
bandera y patriotismo y es que los
franceses independiente de la posición
que tenga han rodeado al presidente en
torno a su liderazgo en europa por el
manejo de esta situación
que tanto son
votantes convencidos de la propuesta de
macrón de la continuidad por otros cinco
años más y simplemente porque se
despierta este sentimiento nacionalista
este sentimiento de unidad que
mencionamos anteriormente y que votan
por quien está liderando el país que es
el que tiene que marcar el camino y el
rumbo que tiene que seguir los
ciudadanos en estas coyunturas
sin duda está jugando es importante que
el jefe del estado entonces haga la
unión del pueblo alrededor de él cuando
estamos en una situación digamos de
crisis pero recordamos que francia no ha
sido atacado francia en este caso
solamente está defendiendo entonces a un
a un país que ha sido agredido entonces
digamos que los franceses no se sienten
en un estado digamos de la cual están
asustados pero realmente también hay
mucha gente que va a votar por macondo
tanto porque están convencidos o porque
ven en él un excelente jefe de estado
sino también porque no quieren caer en
la dicotomía de extrema derecha o
extrema izquierda entonces makoun
digamos que es el candidato de centro
que no es tan extremista ni por un lado
ni por el otro entonces es un poco un
voto útil digamos no necesariamente un
voto de corazón pero más bien un voto
racional de cabeza y es una persona pues
que no lo ha hecho mal finalmente
recuerden que manuel marcó durante su
mandato ha tenido primero los atentados
del bat a clown después ha tenido los
chalecos amarillos después ha tenido el
corrido y ahora la guerra en ucrania
entonces digamos que por todos estos
eventos que han pasado pues su balance
su vilo no está tan mal
aymerich en pasemos a hablar ahora de la
candidata marín de penco por lo decíamos
en la segunda liderando las encuestas se
nota una clara diferencia en el manejo
de la campaña que ha dado para esta
contienda electoral un discurso mucho
más pausado trata de mostrarse mucho más
moderada es una figura con una
trayectoria larguísima la política
francesa y ella misma lo ha dicho nunca
antes ha estado tan cerca de llegar al
elíseo como lo está por lo menos de
acuerdo a la intención de voto para
estos comicios que se puede decir de ese
cambio en el discurso en el cambio
matizando temas como por ejemplo el tema
migratorio dándole fuerza a temas de
feminismo sigue muy fuerte en cuanto a
resaltar los valores republicanos
franceses pero también atacando el islam
la migración de una forma un poco más
matizada digámoslo así
sí bueno como usted lo dijo santiago ya
es conocida tiene experiencia porque va
a ser su tercera participación
en las elecciones presidenciales pero yo
creo que la diferencia con las veces
pasadas es que hay un otro candidato que
intentó superar la que es el ix en un es
un candidato que se presenta como el
candidato de la unión de la derecha él
busca unir la derecha
tradicional de origen el bolista con la
extrema derecha de marín lópez pero él
ha tenido posiciones tiene condiciones
más radicales sobre el tema de la
migración sobre el tema también del
islam negara la diferencia entre islam e
islamismo y yo creo que es sobre todo la
importancia de este nuevo candidato que
es un antiguo periodista que permitió a
mariló vender presentarse como más
moderada
como más experimentado y como más
digamos
comprometida con otros temas que
solamente el tema migratorio solamente
el tema de los no necesidad porque ella
también la requiere de tener un discurso
más social más relacionado con las
dificultades económicas del cotidiano de
los franceses entonces yo creo que es
realmente eso la gran diferencia con las
elecciones pasadas una gran diferencia
manteniendo también un discurso propio
que la identifique y la diferencia de
éste de este candidato sí porque ya
vamos a hablar más adelante hoy en su
opinión sobre esta candidatura de marín
de penn hablando de un discurso
diferente tocando otros temas
fortaleciendo una agenda propia
exacto hace ya unas décadas que mal
independista limpiando la imagen suya y
la imagen de su partido que se llama al
frente nacional que ahora se llama loja
sombrero nacional porque ha hecho eso
porque era el viejo partido de su padre
y su padre es agresivo abiertamente
racista y entonces ella ha intentado
limpiar digamos esta imagen y hacerse
digamos una virginidad política diciendo
miren que yo no soy como mi padre de
hecho lo excluyo del mismo partido digo
yo soy una persona mucho más respetable
yo escucho los franceses soy cercano soy
cercana a ellos pero digamos que eso es
mucha comunicación política en el fondo
el amazon lema nacional sigue con
algunos de los viejos temas de la
extrema derecha he promocionado una una
ciudadanía de doble velocidad con unos
franceses de primera categoría unos que
son de la que nacieron en socios fuera
del territorio que son de segunda
categoría una preferencia nacional
digamos que está claramente
defendida por las salas más
derechistas del partido entonces lo que
hubo fue mucha comunicación
mucho digamos una imagen mucho más light
pero más en el pen sigue siendo una
candidata de extrema derecha ahora se ha
vuelto tan digamos tanto lights que hay
unas personas que la critican han dicho
no a ella que era radical pues la
queremos más radical y es allí donde
aparece el ix de moore y finalmente
diciendo no es que me lo pensé volvió
muy floja yo voy a ser realmente el
candidato el candidato que defiende a
los franceses de verdad y aquí entonces
aparece este fenómeno si finalmente la
puedes llevar a hacer perder porque le
quita 10 porcentaje na en los sondeos si
finalmente ha amenazado fuertemente la
candidatura del epen les ha preocupado
en la candidatura de marín depp en lo
que ha venido cultivando a lo largo de
las semanas este candidato que se puede
decir del eugene ya lo mencionamos un
comentarista de televisión ex periodista
con un discurso muy fuerte muy agresivo
busca deportar cerca de un millón de
inmigrantes en los cinco años que él
pretende estar en el ellis yo como
presidente con políticas muy agresivas
frente a la migración
si él es el candidato de extrema derecha
típico entonces es una persona que tiene
un discurso que se basa que explora
mucho los sentimientos de miedo y habla
mucho de la identidad nacional saben que
en francia tenemos una gran problemática
entonces ser francés originalmente es
compartir unos ideales republicanos que
son herencia de la revolución francesa
pero este modelo de integración
republicano pues ha sido muy fuertemente
criticado y la extrema derecha dice que
hoy en día pues francia está empezando a
caer digamos está perdiendo de su gloria
y eso es culpa digamos de unos
ciudadanos de segunda categoría que
vienen a francia solamente para
delinquir para tener los beneficios del
estado las prestaciones sociales y
entonces hay todo un discurso digamos
que está basado sobre sobre el odio
sobre el miedo y que encuentra en este
país pues un terreno fértil digamos más
que todo después de estar del 19
recordamos sin embargo que es de mujer
si es árabe
y es judío dos de las categorías que
critican mucho en sus discursos es una
completa paradoja aymerich ya me quedan
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero preguntarle por su opinión sobre
este candidato de ley que simula y
también por esa izquierda francesa que
está bastante atomizada quienes podrían
llevarse esos votos que sabemos que para
esta primera vuelta van a estar muy
dispersos
y bueno en cuanto a ese músculo que es
solamente para añadir que es importante
esta devoción de no ser un político
profesional 9 en su presentación de muro
insiste mucho en esta denunció el repite
yo no soy un político profesional y es
un discurso que puede ser recibido de
manera positiva por una parte del
electorado prenda en cuanto al contexto
de consunción frente a la política
tradicional y al rechazo de los partidos
políticos tradicionales los dos grandes
políticos tradicionales probablemente no
van llegar en la segunda vuelta al
partido socialista no hay ninguna duda
la candidata tiene 23 por ciento de los
votos en las encuestas de opinión y la
candidata de los republicanos de la
derecha tradicional tampoco va a llegar
en la segunda vuelta y en cuanto a la
izquierda entonces ahí eficiente mucha
dispersión pero siempre ha tenido muchos
candidatos hay dos comidas dos otros y
trotskistas es algo frecuente el partido
socialista
en gran dificultad en la última lección
y es peor hoy en día el único que tiene
una dinámica favorable es yo - bueno
para el cierre del programa me queda un
minuto eugenia médico como esperan
ustedes que se van a desarrollar estos
comicios habrá una alta abstención hay
mucha apatía por parte de los franceses
van a esperar para la segunda vuelta
cuando ya el panorama esté más definido
comienzo con eugene para esta conclusión
rápidamente por favor si la
participación siempre es alta en francés
si la comparamos con américa latina'
recordamos que a veces arriba del 80% si
hay abstención podemos pensar que por lo
menos el 75% de la gente va a votar y
para la segunda vuelta tendremos menos
abstención seguramente lo que no hay es
mucho entusiasmo no hay entusiasmo
conclusión de eugene y aymerich su
conclusión en cuanto a los votantes al
entusiasmo y ese deseo de ir a las urnas
y
participar
sí bueno veremos que siempre difícil de
predecir no porque depende también del
desarrollo de la campaña electoral pero
hay un riesgo sin embargo en la segunda
vuelta de tener mucho más abstención que
de costumbre en caso de tener nuevamente
a mccoy imagino porque creo que hay
muchos votantes que en la última vez
habían votado a favor de macri que esta
vez van a abstenerse en vez de votar
nuevamente para macri por el rechazo que
viste que es fuerte de su de su primer
mandato
aymerich eugene muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate de
france 24 así está el panorama electoral
en francia de cara a la primera vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales y se lo
hemos contado aquí en el debate de
france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]